hey folks and welcome to the point this
week yogg's cast have cancelled their
half a million dollar kickstarter and
left a bunch of people out of pocket and
that obviously raises a bunch of
questions but my main concern is
where did all that money go the ogscast
you've heard of them right they're a
bunch of internet streamers founded out
of reading in the united kingdom who
gained popularity on youtube initially
through their world of warcraft coverage
but gained mass notoriety through some
fantastically entertaining videos around
minecraft this humble bunch of youtubers
has since grown up to be a rather
profitable media organization boasting
all manners of impressive numbers and
statistics the first uk youtube channel
to reach 1 billion total views for
instance over 7 million subscribers on
their main channel is another one i say
main channel because they now operate a
network of channels which live stream
and post video on the internet around
the clock some of which is done out of a
passion for games others paid for by
publishers but that's a debate for
another day the ox cast are popular and
rightfully so they produce some
entertaining videos i don't know if
there's 70 million subscribers
entertaining but then what the hell
would i know my youtube channel only has
about 2 000 subscribers and most of
those came from a not safe for work
video of me playing that playstation 3
harry potter game
[Music]
yogg's cast are popular so it was no
surprise when back in april 2012 a
kickstarter for a yogscast video game
seemingly backed by the team smashed
through its goal of 250 000 and raised
over half a million dollars the game
entitled the yogg adventures was an open
world sandbox game that would feature
members of the ox cast as characters in
the game the kickstarter looked
professional well thought out it even
had gameplay so it seemed like a pretty
safe bet in the russian roulette of
kickstarter but more than anything it
had yogg's cast's full backing their
branding their voice why are yogs cast
making a game it asked well it turns out
they weren't really the actual work was
being done by winter cool games a team
who in yogscast's words are a team of
talented indie developers and long time
veterans of film and game companies
working at the highest levels of
production well as you can probably
imagine from the fact that i'm even
talking about this that clearly wasn't
the case over 13 thousands of yog cass
fans backed the project and yesterday
over 13 000 people around the world
found out it was canned and that they
wouldn't be getting any refunds
so it turns out winter cool games was
actually a team that at its largest was
merely six contributors being managed by
a single guy a guy who according to a
post made on yogaas forms last week had
a lack of experience in planning and
managing a project of this scope and was
so burdened and stressed out by the
project that he lost his wife and i
quote i almost lost my job too he almost
lost his job why did he have a job
wasn't his job to make this video game
with this team of veterans of film and
game companies that had half a million
dollars in funding surely there are some
questions to be answered well yesterday
lewis brindley of yogscast emailed
backers of the kickstarter with a
frankly bemusing response that indicated
that yogg's hosts aren't interested in
setting things right and are in fact
attempting to put as much distance
between themselves and the project as
possible while this was winter cools
project we put a lot of time energy and
effort into trying to help them realize
their dream it reads winter cool's
project a project that just so happened
to have yogscast branding messaging and
actual words and voices on the
kickstarter page not to mention a link
to yogscast.com is the kickstarter's
homepage and details about yog's cast
limited in the project creator's
biography but the alarm bells really go
off further down the email although
we're under no obligation to do anything
huh
yogscast actually believe that they're
under no obligation to do anything they
think that giving away a bunch of beta
keys for a different game and promising
exclusive content from a whole bunch of
potential partners is some sort of
charity plucked from the bounty of
kindness in their hearts besides the
fact that they are actually legally
responsible as of kickstarter's terms of
use or at least somebody is and that's
when this all starts to make a kind of
sick type of sense
yogscast are trying to distance
themselves both in terms of public
perception and legal culpability and in
doing so are laying all of the blame on
winter cool games a studio led by a guy
who not only clearly didn't have the
resources to create this game was also
divorced in the process almost lost his
day job and seemingly had a breakdown
due to all the stress yogg's cast are
more than willing to use the good faith
they've accrued with their community to
throw their business partner under the
bus and take zero responsibility
themselves first of all morally it is
yogscast's prerogative to ensure that
they protect their fans the very people
who stop them from having day jobs they
might lose so how this project burned
half a million dollars in two years and
only now when it was way beyond too late
the alarm bells went off is frankly
ridiculous but perhaps more importantly
what happened to the half a million
dollars surely this tiny team didn't
actually spend it all so did yogg's cast
take a cut immediately for using their
name did they knowingly duke their
community into thinking that they would
be involved in this project when all
they were doing was licensing their ip
to a third party have they run away with
the majority of the funding and are
hoping that in this daily news world we
find ourselves in people will just
forget about it i might work for a big
corporation but my ability to do what i
do comes from having an audience so it
really infuriates me when i see people
seemingly taking advantage of that
yogscast seemed more than happy in this
situation to throw up their hands and
shout caveat emptor but they're still a
business a business whose dealings have
left 13
647 people out of pocket now that might
not seem like a lot of people when
you've got millions of subscribers and
billions of views but that's still 13
647 people who deserve better answers
[Music]
so
you